exactly what your position is but the
point is that rarely to those in the
academic circles listen to those who are
outside of it especially when those who
are on the outside feel like they have
some Grand idea because you generally
get pitch them left right and Center
when you're an academic and so it's
difficult to separate the wheat from the
chaff with Stefan what I like about you
is that you take your cues from physics
from Jazz which is that if someone
throws you an idea
you play with it and you throw back to
the person you mentioned that this is
how you work with your graduate students
so this is supposed to be or this is
this whole conversation is an example of
what would ordinarily happen behind
closed doors being brought to the public
and so hopefully it's something that
researchers
can aspire to so that's what frames this
conversation this exactly so this
respect that seldom shown in compassion
work between let's say Academia and
those who are outside when they have
large ideas Grand ideas Grand
unification right so on that note on
that note so let me um ask um let me
respond to Sal
uh sure that's great so first of all Sal
uh please call me Stefan
um thank you sir appreciate it yeah and
um
so so I'm gonna push back a little bit
I'm gonna say well you you for the push
I'm gonna push back and agree with you
the first thing I'm going to agree with
is that your idea of let's say the Super
Force meaning that UNIF that
quantization of gravity
can only happen with a unification
scheme where basically there's some
Force let's call it your Super Force or
some Force or
something that underlies all
the force of gravity right and the
forces that quantum mechanics actually
you know um unifies itself so Quantum
field theory was an example of a way of
unifying the three interactions the
three um you know the weak interaction
the strong interaction and the
electromagnetic interaction at least I
mean Quantum field theory is a language
at least okay um you know Quantum fuel
Theory engage invariance right is the
language right or the technology the
conceptual mathematical technology that
underlies those three forces right and
the Super Force you know this
unification of gravity with these other
three forces
this was actually the program of string
theory right
string theory and it's it's parent you
know when people some people call I
think I find this it's parent Theory
actually very interesting Matrix Theory
right the idea that you know what even
underline what underlines the
overarching framework that
um that string theory
comes from is a matrix
um quantum mechanics you just watched a
clip from the theories of everything
channel for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy